we are kicking things off with a new
segment dear drew where
viewers can ask drew barrymore anything
yeah
anything miss drew barrymore how you
doing i'm just so excited to do this
with you guys
i am so excited about this too and honey
you are giving me a good sex in the city
vibe with this carrie bradshaw flower i
love
yes you get a little hand yeah all right
let's jump into uh this first question
here okay
this person says dear drew social media
has been taking over my life during this
pandemic we have five likes
people are calling back how do i find
the balance
you can turn off your social media apps
and just use it as
a phone i also take like
day-long breaks or week-long breaks put
it down
and like walk away from it oh my god
you're the unicorn truly you are the
unicorn it's
liberating all right let's get to the
second one uh dear drew this person says
you recently shared
that you have been dating online oh he's
cute
so what is the secret to dating in this
crazy time
it's exhausting i may or may not have
written this question
just saying aha you know it's funny
because i was like
not okay with dating apps i really like
to pay attention to the gut instinct
if something is telling you go for it go
for it if something is telling you like
run run
all right here's our last question drew
this one says dear drew
one of my mom friends is desperate to be
a
cool mom including embarrassing tick
tocks not like a regular mom i'm a cool
mom
how do i tell her she needs to focus
more on being a parent
and less to being a girlfriend to her
daughter i am just gonna say
that your parent is not your friend
they're your parents
and we should not be trying to be
friends with our children
i'm never going to lie to my daughters
about my journey but my kids need to be
able to rely on me
as their mother it's harder to be their
parent but it's the right choice
oh i love that dropping gyms dropping
all sorts of juices
by the way this was like the best thing
i've ever gotten to do i can't even tell
you
thank you so much e.t